The 2020 election was a stunning rebuke toprohibitionists and a crucial milestone inthe unraveling
of the disastrous U.S.War on Drugs.
Across the country and by overwhelming margins, American voters came out in favor of legalizing marijuana,
removing criminal penalties for psychedelic use, and opening new possibilities for treating drug addiction
as a public health concern.
The biggest victory was in Oregon,where voters overwhelmingly approved a measure
that will make it the first state to eliminate thepossibility of jail time for possession of heroin, cocaine, oxycodone,
and every other narcotic.
Instead, those possessing small amounts ofdrugs could be hit with at most a $100 fine.
It's a really bold experiment.
It essentially embodies this idea that, look,arresting people and locking them up forusing drugs is not very effective.
So let's stoparresting and putting them in prison, and insteadset up education treatment recovery programs,
usethe money from the legal marijuana market to fundall of that.
It's the harm reduction approachwritten into law, across the board.
Oregon also passed Measure 109, making itthe first state to legalize psilocybin,
the main psychoactiveingredient in magic mushrooms.
In 2018, the Food and Drug Administration grantedpsilocybin “breakthrough therapy” status
for treatment-resistant depression.
In Washington, D.C., voters opted by a marginof 3 to 1 to require that law enforcementmake the prosecution of use,
possession, andcultivation, of entheogenic plants and fungi,like psilocybin mushrooms, its lowest priority.
The most important thing to keepin mind is it is a referendum in the sort ofclassic sense.
It does not change law in anyway. It simply says, "Look, government of DC:
we, the people, think that the policeand the district attorneys should stoparresting and prosecuting people
for psychedelic plants. So please do that.
Mississippi, Arizona, South Dakota,New Jersey, and Montana all passedinitiatives
allowing marijuana to be soldfor either medical or recreational use.
Moore says that there’s a danger that some of thelegal structures established by these ballot measures,
such as in Arizona,will repeat the mistakes of other states,
where regulated cartels dominate.
It really is designed to give the existing medicalmarijuana providers control of the market
and not let anybody else into the market, which iskind of crazy.
It also establishes all kinds of rules governing the market that have been pretty well shown in other states
not to work very well.
So on the one hand, itlegalizes marijuana. On the other hand,it sets up a market
that is destined to be fullof problems and corruption and crony nonsense.
But, so far, a clear take away from the 2020election
is that the American public has had enough of the government locking people incages
for putting mind altering substances  into their own bodies.
And the tragic War on Drugs is finally coming to an end.